MINUTES.
MILLIONS ARE WONDERING, AND WE
HAVE SOME CREATIVE SOLUTIONS.
THIS IS AMERICA AND SHUT DOWN,
DAY 21.
WE ARE ALL ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
DARKNESS THIS HAS BROUGHT.
THE MORE THAN 10,000 AMERICANS
WHO HAVE NOW LOST THEIR LIVES IN
COUNTLESS FORMS HAVE HAD THEIR
LIVES UPENDED.
BUSINESS IS FROZEN, PARENTS
FRUSTRATED, CHILDREN ARE
CONFUSED AND WORKERS UNEMPLOYED.
THERE ARE SOME AND WE NEEDED
THESE HOPEFUL SIGNS EMERGING.
NOW, WHILE NEW YORK IS STILL
SUFFERING GREATLY WITH ITS
COVERT DEATHS, THE DAILY NUMBERS
ARE ACTUALLY STABILIZING AND
THERE ARE OTHER POSITIVE SIGNS.
>> THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE DOWN.
THE ICU ADMISSIONS ARE DOWN.
END OF THE DAILY INTEGRATIONS
ARE DOWN.
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD SIGNS.
AND AGAIN, IT WOULD SUGGEST A
POSSIBLE FLATTENING OF THE CURVE
CURVE.
>> Laura: EARLIER THAN SOME
PEOPLE THOUGHT PERHAPS.
WE WILL BE WATCHING.
THE WEST COAST AS FAR AHEAD OF
NEW YORK AND THE GOOD NEWS
CATEGORY.
THINGS ARE LOOKING UP IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST COVID-19 BOTH IN
WASHINGTON STATE’S AND
CALIFORNIA.
SOME STATES ARE DOING SUCH A
GOOD JOB AT BUDGETING AND
REALLOCATING THEIR OWN RESOURCES
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO SHARE SOME
OF THEIR MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE, A DEMOCRAT,
ANNOUNCED SUNDAY THAT
WASHINGTON STATE WILL BE
RETURNING MORE THAN 400
VENTILATORS THAT IT RECEIVED
FROM THE STRATEGIC NATIONAL
STOCKPILE SO THEY CAN THEN BE
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER STATES.
ON SATURDAY, OREGON’S
GOVERNOR KATE BROWN ANNOUNCED
THAT HER STATE CAN AFFORD TO
SHARE 140 VENTILATORS WITH
NEW YORK.
>> President Trump: YOU LOOK
AT MOST PLACES, YOU COULD CALL
IT THE BUMP OR THE HILL OR THE
MOUNTAIN OR WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
DO BUT IT’S VERY FLAT.
THEY HAVE A COUPLE OF TOUGH
ONES.
NEW JERSEY HAS BEEN VERY TOUGH
AND NEW YORK HAS BEEN VERY
TOUGH.
LOOK AT SO MANY OF THE STATES
AND HOW WELL THEY ARE DOING.
>> Laura: THAT’S GOOD TO HEAR.
LIKE YOU, I’M WONDERING GOING TO
BEGINGET OUR COUNTRY BACK?
>> WOULD BE BACK TO NORMAL
BEFORE THERE’S A VACCINE
AVAILABLE?
>> BACK TO NORMAL MEANS LIKE IT
WAS BEFORE THERE WAS A
CORONAVIRUS PROBLEM.
I DON’T THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN.
WHEN WE GET BACK TO NORMAL WE
WILL GO BACK GRADUALLY TO THE
POINT WE CAN FUNCTION AS A
SOCIETY.
IF YOU WANT TO GET TO
PRECORONAVIRUS, THAT MIGHT NOT
EVER HAPPEN.
>> Laura: AT THE PRESIDENT
DIDN’T SEEM LIKE HE WAS
COMPLETELY THRILLED WITH THAT
ANSWER.
>> President Trump: I THINK WE
CAN GET MORE THAN BACK TO NORMAL
FROM AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT,
ACTUALLY BE BETTER, MORE THAN
BACK TO NORMAL.
BUT I WOULD AGREE THAT I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE A VACCINE BUT
IMMEDIATELY I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
A THERAPEUTIC.
AND I THINK WE ARE GETTING VERY
CLOSE.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF
THERAPEUTIC, SOME OF THE MEDIA
AND THE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENTS
CONTINUE THIS BIZARRE ASSAULT ON
A DECADES OLD DRUG
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE THAT’S BEING
USED BY DOCTORS WORLDWIDE, AND I
MEAN WORLDWIDE, TO TREAT
COVID-19 PATIENTS.
ESPECIALLY SEEING PROMISE IN
EARLY INTERVENTION.
TO GET A SENSE OF HOW POLITICAL
THE CRITICISM HAS BECOME, CHECK
THIS OUT.
>> WE ARE FOCUSING SO MUCH ON
THE HYDROXYHYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, W
TALKING ABOUT THE SPIKE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT’S BEING
SEEN BY PEOPLE FORCED TO STAY
INSIDE.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPACT ON INDIGENOUS AND
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY IS.
AND WE ARE NOT TALK ENOUGH ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF THE CORONAVIRUS ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> Laura: NOT TO SAY THOSE
AREN’T ALL IMPORTANT ISSUES,
THEY ARE.
BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS CAN WE NOT?
AND WHAT HE ALSO SAID THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AZITHROMYCIN
IS BEING USED IN HIS OWN
HOSPITAL.
NOW I WILL SAY WHAT I SAY ALMOST
EVERY DAY.
IF AT ALL POSSIBLE SHORT OF A
VACCINE, WE NEED A CHEAP
SCALABLE THERAPEUTIC.
BUT REMEMBER, THE DRUG COMPANIES
DON’T MAKE THE REAL MONEY OFF OF
OLD GENERIC DRUGS.
SO FAR WE HAVE A CONTROLLED
STUDY IN CHINA, ALBEIT ON THE
SMALL SITE.
WE HAVE A STUDY FROM ONE OF
EUROPE’S TOP EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND
WE HAVE OBSERVATIONAL DATA FROM
AROUND THE GLOBE THAT SHOWS THAT
HYDROXY AND AS THEY THROW CAN
DROP A PATIENT’S VIRAL LOAD AND
SEND THEM HOME FROM THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY DROPPED THE VIRAL LOAD AND
THEY WILL NOT SHOW THAT VIRUS IS
MUCH AS THEY WOULD WITHOUT IT.
NOW ANDREW CUOMO IS EVEN SEEING
THE PROMISE.
>> WE HAVE ALLOWED USAGE OF THE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WITH THE
AZITHROMYCIN PACKS AND HOSPITALS
AT THEIR DISCRETION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GOING
TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY TO
NEW YORK PHARMACIES.
THERE HAS BEEN ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE THAT IT IS PROMISING,
THAT’S WHY WE ARE GOING AHEAD.
IF DOCTORS HAVE TO PRESCRIBE IT,
ANECDOTALLY IT HAS BEEN
POSITIVE.
>> Laura: ANOTHER HOT SPOT IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THE BENEFITS AS
WELL.
>> THESE DRUGS DON’T REPRESENT A
SILVER BULLET OR A MAGIC WAND.
HOWEVER.
MANY MEDICAL DOCTORS HAVE CHOSEN
TO PRESCRIBE THESE DRUGS TO
RELIEVE SYMPTOMS OF THE VIRUS IN
SOME PATIENTS.
POSITIVE RESULTS IN A PATIENT BY
THESE DRUGS COULD POTENTIALLY
ALLOW OUR VENTILATOR NEEDS TO
DECREASE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THAT’S THE
LOUISIANA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
OF COURSE NOTHING SHORT OF A MAP
VACCINE A MAGIC WAND BUT DRUGS
CAN RELEASE PRESSURE ON
HOSPITALS AND ICUS HELPING US TO
AVERT A TOTAL COLLAPSE OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, WHICH WAS
THE WHOLE POINT OF FLATTENING
THE CURVE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SAVING PATIENTS AND SAVING
HOSPITALS.
THERE IS AN INTERESTING NEW POLL
BY JUST THE NEWS POLLING AND
SCOTT RASMUSSEN.
30% OF AMERICANS SAY THE MOST
DIFFICULT IMPACT HAS BEEN ON
THEIR LOSS OF INCOME.
27% SITE FINDING SUPPLIES.
OF 23% SHOWS ISOLATION AND
BOREDOM.
ONLY 4% OF AMERICANS CITED THEIR
HEALTH.
TO AS THEIR TOP CONCERN.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE ARE JUST PRAGMATIC, THEY
KNOW THE RISK OF WALKING OUT THE
DOOR EVERY DAY AND THEY WANT TO
BE CAREFUL AND HAVE COMMON SENSE
BUT THEY KNOW THAT WE MUST
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE INCLUDING
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT THE
SITUATION OF BEING LOCKED IN AND
SHUT AND IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
THEY KNOW EVERY DAY WE ARE IN
SHUTDOWN IS ANOTHER DAY OF
SELF-INFLICTED DEVASTATING
WOUNDS TO AMERICAN FAMILIES AND
TO OUR COUNTRY AS A WHOLE.
>> President Trump: IF WE WANT
TO FINISH THIS WAR, WE HAVE TO
GET BACK TO WORK.
WE DON’T WANT TO BE DOING THIS
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
THIS COUNTRY WASN’T MEANT FOR
THIS.
WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
>> Laura: WE NEED AN AMERICAN
RESURRECTION SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.